so can this from forbes car shoppers
on limited budgets can't get a break the
average transaction price for a new
vehicle is expected to rise to a record
38 255 in may
according to jd power sending many
consumers looking for bargains on used
car lots no such luck the combination of
high demand and high wholesale prices
dealers pay to acquire inventory has led
to record high prices for
used cars toby russell co-ceo at
onlineusedvehiclemarketplaceshift.com
told forbes
the surge in used vehicle demand is
causing bizarre
bizarre behavior in the form of used car
prices appreciating given the strong
demand for consumers
the tight supply situation it seems
likely that used
vehicle prices already at all time highs
will continue to rise there's a silver
lining for those looking to trade in
their current vehicles
uh vehicles demand such as pickup trucks
crossovers suvs are bringing top dollar
and uh the amount paid on a site right
now is increasing 15
to 20 percent in some cases 30 percent
over the last year for the same used car
first time in history used cars have
gone up in
value well they haven't over a period of
a year but that same exact vehicle
all caused by the covet economic
disruption
yep uh people in factories not making
cars that's right
also i read about people not in
factories making cars
that's right well i also saw that be
because travel was
literally almost suspended that rental
car companies are a big source of used
cars
as well because they'll order cars from
manufacturers
they'll rent them to folks like us and
then after a certain point they'll sell
them back
and that becomes a part of the used car
inventory as well so you have two things
manufacturing as a whole
also orders from uh carmel companies so
it's really fascinating but i will tell
you this
i'm in the market uh i i can't even
believe i'm saying this dave my oldest
is gonna be 16 in november so i'm
already beginning to look
just to see is there something right now
that i could jump on and get it get a
great deal put it in the garage
and for him and so i've been looking a
lot just a direct to
consumer uh facebook marketplace is a
great option there there's all kinds of
auto trader
and so outside the dealer i still see in
fact i spent a good time this weekend
good amount of time looking there still
are great deals if you're buying
directly uh from someone else but to the
dealers there's no question the prices
are up i see that
yeah and so the other thing that's
happened was
um i bought a used car last week and i
bought it at market
it didn't pay it was not up um took a
little
work though yeah and i actually looked
at the new version of that car
and uh there's such a shortage on it the
dealers are charging 20 000 over
sticker for that particular car
and uh now it's an expensive car but
they're adding a premium on it
on a on a new car because they they gave
me a quote on the new one and i'm like
uh dude i buy it invoice and guys like
not today you don't
right and not right now you don't even
sir across town this same brand is
selling these for 20 000 over sticker he
said well i'll tell you a sticker and i
went
i think we're going to go used so i
bought a used car and so
uh but it's uh uh man
i mean it the this disruption and it's
just like the new housing like the new
housing market
is screwed up and so it's screwing up
the used housing market
and then people go cray-cray and they
get the chasing stuff and get the fever
and it's like oh god oh god i'm not
gonna be able to get what i want it's
like a little kid on the cereal aisle
having a hissy fit
and then they over pay for stuff and so
um
yeah i used vehicles uh there's a
shortage and
um definitely and there's a shortage for
uh uh the new because there's a shortage
on new
because the factories were not dialed up
and it's gonna take a little while for
it to catch up so it's like it's gonna
take a little while for lumber
supply demand to catch up right now
lumber's selling for more than gold
it's unbelievable it's true and drywall
i've talked to a builder friend of mine
brought sheets of drywall exploding
everything
plywood the glue going into plywood
there's a shortage on
they're saying it's going to go up 4x
before it comes back down but it'll come
back down and these used cars will as
well
yeah so plenty but the good news is if
you're out there and you like just
decided i'm going to get out of debt and
you're like
i've got to get rid of this really
stinking overpriced
i bought too much car yeah you know i
got a thirty thousand dollar car
you know twenty eight thousand or oh
thirty two thousand on it this is a
great time it really
is it really is a great time to move
down in car
uh it's a great time to get rid of a car
yeah that you that you're trapped in
so that's the good news i'm curious to
know what the trade-in value is how much
it's gone up because traditionally
that's
way way lower than what you can get if
you sell it yourself yeah so
you know the other parts of this article
which i didn't read uh but the man
mannheim is the largest wholesaler the
auction houses
that wholesale to the dealers and um
they're seeing across the board about a
10 to a 15
bump wow and uh so that's that's and
then of course that's
of a used car going across the dealer
auction
dealer puts that back on his lot and um
you know they're not in the business to
lose money so they're gonna be marking
it up that much so
we're seeing this uh the the i
knew there were going to be shortages
because of covid we talked about that at
this time last year because these
factories all just shut down
and it took them forever to come back
um and you knew they were going to be
shortage but what i didn't for some
reason i didn't i was dumb i
should have been obvious i did not see
the price increases as a result
because it creates a shortage and drives
prices up simple supply demand curve
stuff
and you know you get into that and uh
but you're
right the um the uh
rental car companies hertz it owns
dollar that sponsors the dollar car
rental studio so we've had discussions
with them
i didn't realize until we were
sponsoring them and we were actually
talking to them at this time last year
because
no one's renting cars and so they're all
screwed they're all
going into bankruptcy they're all you
know right on the teetering on the edge
and what they did was they just sold off
half of their inventory
liquidated these used cars like crazy
they dumped them on the market
well now the market's gone the other way
and now they can't get the new cars
and so it's gone back the other way so
they a lot of rental car companies have
a shortage
of inventory to rent to you oh we see
that all the time it's not unusual
very normal it it really is interesting
and hertz is the third largest car
dealer in america
massive yeah that's amazing well you
know it's like you said dave
it's like we had all this extra supply
but we burned through it and now the
factories are trying to catch back up so
it's going to be this way for a while
i created a new thing as you were
talking you the msrp
now it's iiwii it is what it is
you like that so don't buy a new car
anyways we don't tell you to buy a new
car unless you unless you've got it and
then some
but now it's the time to stay away yeah
yeah just just
here's a plan not right now yeah i don't
need it that bad
don't need it that bad